toujours cette question ces remarques la
robe de mon temps c'était pas comme ça
c'est absolument faux puisque les les
gens qui ont maintenant mettons 40 ans
inconnu ont été absous par exemple à
saint germain des prés il avait aussi
les cheveux longs il avait une mode que
tout le monde critique et que leur pays
a critiqué les donc c'est un éternel
recommencement toute façon il n'y a pas
besoin d'en faire un drame on dirait les
jeunes de maintenant c'est pas vrai les
jeunes de maintenant ils font beaucoup
moins de choses qui à l'époque dans le
fond en france spécialement il ya des
tas de choses qui me
je trouve les gens cons
moi évoluer qu'en angleterre
par leur esprit critique tout
les gens seraient
oui
ils ont stagné
qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez je
reproche tout c'est important l'argent
pour vous bien sûr c'est un temps
vigeant videmment cette impuissance je
ne suis pas l'idéaliste mois qui va dire
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur c'est
stupide pour moi l'argent fait le
bonheur moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] moi
joueurs sans argent je m'emmerde je suis
parent bien je ne suis pas heureux il
faut mon petit bain chaud il faut mais
même âme et mon petit steak tous les
midis moi j'aime ça et sans argent il y
en a